okay as chair of division two of the
house finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
education please note that there is no
fiscal location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order one
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
of this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal at leg dot state
dot nh dot us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
the lba staff are on the meeting
assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
whether there is anyone else in the room
with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
so representative lin would you please
call the role
yes thank you madam chair uh
representative bucco
uh yes thank you i'm present i'm at home
in conway and no one else is in the room
thank you representative danielson
danielson is not here
uh representative heath miry heath here
in manchester and
i'm home alone all right and i'm bob
lynn
i'm home uh at my home in windham uh
no one else is in the room but my wife
is uh president of the house
uh representative uh murray i as i
understand is going to be joining us
shortly but is not here right this
minute um
representative petry yes i'm
uh here in the house in farmington
and it's not the cayman islands and the
dog and the wife is running around the
halls as usual
thank you and representative humber yes
i'm in my home in kearsarge
and my husband is here at the moment
but he's going to go out shopping so
we'll see what he brings back
all right thank you that completes the
attendance and i'll know
i'll make a note when uh when
representative murray arrives
okay uh mick is uh
caitlin ready to uh come on board
uh yeah we've got a a few members from
the department of education on hand
and i'm gonna bring them all in so they
good morning can you hear me yes we can
and uh thank you for joining us caitlyn
i know that
uh this will be an extremely interesting
day
so uh i'm looking forward to um
hearing what you have to say so we
always
yeah we always think it's very
interesting and we're glad that you take
the opportunity to
to listen to us talk about these massive
programs that we manage over here at the
department of education
so so good morning um for the record i'm
caitlin davis i'm a division director
at the department of education we are
here today to present
to you the department of education's
budget requests
for house bill 2 and to go through the
variety of different
accounts that they're in and to kind of
discuss and explain
the purpose of the programs so
on the call with me today we have the
various different staff that oversee the
programs in the education
trust fund those staff you can see them
all here
um as of right now we will probably have
them turn off their cameras or mickey
i'll probably have you add them
as they're speaking but just for
introduction purposes so
the first topic you will hear about
today is state special education aid
which those of you who have been
doing this for a long time know this as
catastrophic aid
rebecca fredette she's there on the
phone and she has two of her staff
lisa and bridget staying behind her she
will be first up to talk about
that program um next up on the call we
can where we will have eric falworth you
have eric
down here on the call as well he is the
administrator of career and tech
education
um and he will be talking about tuition
and transportation for cte centers
next up we have amy clark amy clark is
the
administrator of the bureau of school
facilities and safety
and she will be talking about a variety
of different school aides
today including building aid the public
school infrastructure fund and lease aid
to charter public schools
and last up you have mark maganello you
guys are all very familiar with mark he
very fortunately now works for the
department of education
um and he will be talking about charter
school aid and adequacy aid
so before we get up to becky i'm just
going to share my screen and give you a
quick
[Music]
synopsis of our presentation today um so
these are the funds that we're going to
be talking about
so this is the information from the
budget you have the appropriations from
the last two years
as well as the appropriation that is in
the governor's budget
these funds are now in the
education trust fund with exception of
one small one the public school lease
aid fund
but historically some of these funds
have been in the general funds
in the general fund and then some of
them have been in the education trust
fund
as of fiscal year 20 and 21 at building
a
tuition and transportation and special
education aid we're all moved into the
education
trust fund so the lines that you would
follow in the budget
may not be the exact lines that we've
seen in the past
the accounting units have changed but we
for historical purposes we have included
them here so you can kind of follow
the history so each one of these funds
we're going to talk about today
i'm just a reminder that these funds are
now paid out of the education trust fund
the education trust fund is established
in law under rsa 198
39 and that has a variety of dedicated
revenue sources that goes to the
education trust fund for the purpose of
distributing these grants each year
these grants go to publix public schools
and public charter schools
they equate to about a billion dollars
of state aid dispersed across the state
every single year
um and i just want to remind the
committee that
um these funds that you're seeing here
in front of you are 100
flow through that means they go directly
to the schools and none of it is
maintained by the department of
education
for the purpose of staff and whatnot
those are funded in various other areas
of our budget that will be covered
by tammy vallencourt at a different time
so with that introduction i'm going to
hand the mic over to
rebecca ferdet who will be talking about
good morning thank you caitlin um as
caitlin said i'm rebecca ferdinand i'm
the state director of special education
and i'm going to
review for you special education aid
i'm just going to share my screen with
you
special education oh hold on
special education aid formerly known as
catastrophic aid is
funds that offer us financial assistance
to defray the costs for special
education
um distributed under rsa 186 c 18
3 to a responsible school district the
school district may be eligible for
reimbursement
only for those direct costs which are
included in the iep of a child with a
disability
and which qualify as special education
and related services
districts submit invoices for payments
made for the cost of special education
services
and the state reimburses for the
allowable costs based on the previous
year
so rsa 186 c18 requires the state to be
level for 80 percent
of the cost above the three and a half
times the estimated state average
expenditure per pupil and the school
year preceding the year of the
distribution
up to 10 times the estimated state
average expenditure per pupil
for the school year preceding the year
of distribution
we are liable for all costs in excess of
10 times the estimated state average
expenditure
per pupil for the school year precede
preceding the year of distribution
if in any year the amount appropriated
for distribution as special education
aid exceeds the allotted
um allocated amount excuse me the
district's reimbursement shall be
prorated
and so there are times that we have had
to prorate so the school district is
liable for the three and
a half times the cost per pupil
plus 20 of the additional cost the state
is responsible for 80
and there are not enough if there are
not enough funds to cover the 80
the cost will be prorated so we have an
example
so if the estimated state average
expenditure per pupil is around 16 000
and then three and a half times that
would be the 59
217. the total allowable special
education cost is the 99
845. that's what
they have spent on the student the cap
is going to cover
the 59 000 which the district pays and
then that cost of four that
forty thousand six hundred and twenty
seven is above the cap
we then take that and we would cover
eighty percent which is thirty five
thirty two thousand five hundred and one
sorry my
numbers are and then if you were able to
give them the hundred percent
we would give them the thirty two
thousand five hundred and one
and the district would still be
responsible for sixty seven
thousand three hundred and forty three
that's when we're able to pay the
hundred percent
um from the state aid i will say that
this year was the first time since 2008
we have been able to pay that hundred
percent
um typically we have to prorate it so we
do have another example that shows
um what the cost could be going forward
so if we take the same numbers but we
have to prorate that cost here
um at 70 percent the districts our share
goes down to
hundred 22 one and the district
responsibility goes up to seventy seven
thousand
ninety three dollars excuse me
four yes um when you said this year
were you talking about 2021 when
we had the 80 percent so um
it would have been for let me get my
dates right
i'm just going to make sure i get the
right dates i want to make sure at least
it would have been for the 1920 school
year
we were able to provide the 80 and 100
um and we didn't have to prorate the
hundred percent we never prorate the 80
but we do at times have to prorate that
but that 100
if we don't have enough funds so this
year which
we we get all of our documentation in
july
and we review all of those that's why it
kind of gets in my head as this year
but it is for the previous year yeah and
then it's paid out by december so
we just finished that in december and we
were able to pay it out at
the 100 that we um that is required
uh representative lynn you had a
question
yes thank you uh just a quick question
when you say if there are not enough
funds it has to be prorated
could you just um explain what what the
formula
is for the proration how does that work
sorry i have somebody in my ear telling
me what i meant to do
so that's someone you just went so go to
the next one that's just like that
right there that explains the probation
so
it what would happen is we would so if
we take the same student that i had
talked about with the hundred percent um
we would still pay the 80
which is here which is the 35. but then
it once that gets over the cap
we can't pay am i saying this right
no i'm not saying this right sorry
so let me just clarify that this is my
first time doing this
so i'm still learning all of this as we
go that's why there are two people
sitting behind me
oh you're doing fine don't worry you're
doing fine yeah so we take in all of the
special education
and we look at everything that is um
pros we process it we look through
make sure that everything is accurate
everything is appropriate
um that they've spent their money on
funds that they're supposed to and then
we look at
how much that will be so we say you know
say that um everything that's turned
under
into us comes up to 10 million dollars i
know that's not the number it's just a
bigger number than that and i'm gonna
work with a smaller one
say that it's 10 million dollars but
we've only been allocated through this
fund eight million dollars
so then we would prorate everybody to
only spend
the eight million dollars because i'm
not able to do the 10 million dollars so
if
so once we've gone through everything
we've looked at everything that's
submitted to us
we make a determination as to whether we
can pay it at a hundred percent
or if we would need to um prorate it so
that it's at a lower rate than that
hundred percent
okay can i just ask a follow-up
certainly so so you just understand when
when you say like you use the 10 million
dollars as just as an example i
understand
so am i understanding that the way the
proration works then
is you let's say that that 10 million
dollars just as an example
represented 100 students who were
getting special education
um uh aid so you would then
you would it would be on that basis
you'd say okay
we only have we don't have 10 we only
have um
uh 10 we've the total expenditure has
been 10 million dollars for special
education
that's over the you know it's over the
limit where we start to pay
but we only have eight million dollars
to pay
um we're gonna divide that eight million
dollars by a hundred
and figure out how much each of those
hundred students that are getting
special education would get
is that that's that kind of the way it
works representative flynn i believe the
next slide that becky's going to
present is actually going to help
explain exactly what that question is so
it might make it a little bit more clear
i'm sorry i'm probably way ahead of
myself
no it's great it means you're
understanding it so representative heath
i'll hold my question until they finish
the next slide
okay thank you so this this
um so this i didn't realize i was going
on to this side thank you caitlyn
so this slide is going to show you what
we've done for each year and it gives
you that
this each fiscal year it gives you the
count for students that we
have um had apply for special education
aid because not everybody will apply for
special education aid unless they meet
the cap
it gives you what the districts have
expended it tells you what the full
entitlement
would have been owed by the state and
then it tells you what we paid
so if you look at um 2003 it said that
our entitlement was
22 276 but we were only able to pay
17 561.
um no that's not right because it says
we paid 100
you need to come over here you need to
come over here
i'm going to have lisa talk really quick
so i'll let me
i'll take over for just a second and
lisa can correct me um so in 2003 there
was a the formula worked a little bit
different
um so but let's look at 2018 for example
so in 2018 which is like online 22
um there were 822 kids that were
determined
eligible for catastrophic aid by the
department of education
meaning school districts submitted all
of the expenses with the associated kids
we reviewed the expenses and determined
that those kids had expenses over three
and a half times the average cost per
pupil and we could
then begin to reimburse the school
district so the school district expended
80 that 80 million dollars of allowable
expenses associated with
those 822 kids i just want to point out
it is
80 million dollars of allowable special
education expenses so there may have
been other expenses associated with
those kids
but they were not special education
specific kids
um so of that 80 million and they may
have had other expenses but they may
have not been determined but allowable
by the departure department
there are some expenses that are not
allowable for reimbursement under
catastrophic stats
slash state special education aid so
the state determined that out of the 80
million dollars their proportional
share so the amount above the three and
a half times
and then the amount um at 80 should have
been
30 million dollars 30 million 800 000
that's what the department should have
paid if we had the full appropriated
amount
however that specific year with the
department was appropriated in our state
budget 22 million dollars
meaning that we could only pay 22
million dollars
22 million dollars divided by 30 million
dollars is 72 percent
meaning every single school district
received a proration of 72
of the full catastrophic aid bill that
they would have received
so had we had the full appropriation
that specific year
we would have paid 38 30 million dollars
but we only paid 22 million dollars to
the school districts
in fiscal year 21 is the first year in
very recent memory since
it looks like 2008 in the spreadsheet
here that we had enough appropriation to
fully fund all of our kids in the state
meaning that school districts submitted
742 eligible kids with 79 million
dollars of expenses occurred at the
local level
29 million dollars of that was owed to
them for the state formula and we had 30
million dollars in appropriation so we
do have excess appropriation
that we um will end up lapsing or
paying for or or giving to 402 pla
court-ordered placements depending on
the available approach
appropriation in that line so the last
two years um
so those of you that were working on the
budget in the last two years we were
prorated at 94
excuse me is it lisa yes okay
um so
just just for clarity the school
districts has to pay
the 3.5 percent
the three 3.5 times yes correct so they
pay all of the all of their invoices
to reach cap and above so for the whole
year from july 1st to june 30th
they pay all their expenses and then
come july 1st we um
we review those they submit those to us
by
july august and then we review them
okay uh representative lynn did that
grand mute sorry i think it did you um
so the i i i as i understand it then the
the the allocation if you don't have if
you can't
fund 100 it's based on
the s on how on the school districts
as opposed to the individual
the individual uh children is
is that correct yes okay thank you thank
you
representative peace thank you madam
chair um
we tried real hard to fully fund last
year
i'm looking at your numbers i see a
trend
that though across the state our
student numbers are decreasing
in some places significantly i see a
continued
increase in the numbers of students
eligible for catastrophic aid and that's
just my first
question is do we know why secondly
one of the things that i've always been
concerned about catastrophic aid
or that or special ed aid we call it now
is that
the manner in which it's paid out now
it's paid out
and and school districts get a check in
december
of the following year and it comes into
municipalities of school districts as
usually they consider it revenue so when
you're doing your budget process
for the year to come
if you have students that you had not
anticipated
it can throw off your whole budget and
it's really a hardship
for school districts and sometimes
they find themselves especially our
little school districts
in a difficult situation has
there ever been consideration given
to collecting the information um because
i know it's it's uploaded
in in your special ed system
is there ever been consideration given
to
um payments to payments
so that school districts would be made
more whole
during the course of the school year
and not have to anticipate um
what um the catastrophic aid
payment coming to them might be um
can you respond i'll let thank you
respond a little bit but
the first is is it's that's challenging
for the department because of the way
that
the grant works um if their
the legislation said to make the payment
no matter what the appropriation was
um then we would be able to do that but
because
it has historically been up until this
year prorated the department of
education needs to know the total amount
of expenses
before we can reimburse the school
district so we make sure that we have an
even proration across the board um in
schools
occur different expenses at a different
time so they may have a kid that starts
out for the year for example then they
wouldn't
submit the catastrophic the kid in in
this catastrophic aid pool
because they think that you know their
expenses are not going to be
the three and a half times because
remember three and a half times is about
sixty thousand dollars per kid
um and then it gets to the point that oh
this kid needed
you know a few additional services or
maybe we actually do feel that the best
the best thing for this child is an
out-of-district placement and this kid
is now all of a sudden
has a higher cost than his original
originally anticipated
so those costs are not necessarily
evenly spread out through the year
so unless the legislation specifically
said to pay this
catastrophic aid bill no matter what it
was without the proration it wouldn't
make sense to do that for the department
so
we would need to change um how the
actual pool works
mary you you were breaking up just a
little bit because i was interrupting
you i'm sorry
i'm sorry just um my second question
about the um
it seems like there's a trend that the
numbers are going up and these are
significantly disabled children
um do we have any indication is it being
the autism numbers that are increasing
so quickly or
so the numbers of students that are um
being submitted for
special education aid have decreased but
it i believe it's the costs of the um if
you look at the numbers for 2021 we're
at 742.
so those numbers kind of stayed it looks
like they stayed somewhat in the same
way
i'm sorry that's okay
i i think the other uh other problem
with that
of trying to pay more often is
when does a student meet the three
uh the 3.5 times and so you
uh you know they they may meet it in the
first six months or they
may not meet it until the last two
months so
it would be um i think it would be very
difficult
to try to
try to do something but i think that the
most school districts or maybe i don't
know
everything but a lot of the school
districts do
have a reserve fund
that they put aside just for
uh special education needs for
you know to to support it until such
time
as they um as they get the uh the money
from
uh from the state for for uh
special education aid
yes there are many districts that will
develop their own special education
trust funds
for situations just as you mentioned
okay i don't see any further questions
so
if you wouldn't mind we'll ask you to go
ahead
all right um so i don't think
i i'm the last part of this section
shows you
um by town how much was put out for
um special education aid and the totals
for those each district that put in for
special education aid
i'm not going to go through each one for
you but and there's two pages of those
and did you have any other questions i
have something to do
lisa would like to add something lisa
moody was our fiscal person and um has
moved to a different job
she's been assisting us as we work on
these physical pieces so if you wanted
to add something
right so um so i just text caitlyn and
asks as a reminder so we
also use um
the um i keep on call it cat aids so i
apologize the special education aid
for the budget we use that budgeted
amount to meet
our um our fiscal our maintenance fiscal
support that we need for our ida grant
which is a grant that we give out to
it's a 40 i think 47 million
grand that we give out to the school
districts we use
the spend aid amount on budget amount to
help meet
our state fiscal support
so it's important that we keep that
budgeted amount and not
lower it because if we lower it then we
could
any questions on that yes representative
heath
oh thank you you know that was a really
critically
important point um in terms of
maintenance of effort
for those we get a pretty sizable
amount of special ed federal funding
um not exactly what we'd like to have of
course
but um what is the level of maintenance
of effort that you need to see
um from the general fund budget that is
a great
question i do not have the answer off
the top of my head
bridget and i are working on that
tomorrow um
but we use the budgeted amount for um
that we have for our for the
court-ordered students
and we also use a portion of the
adequacy
funds and you should probably mention
colvid for this year
representative uh lynn
yes i you know i'm sorry i could you i i
i don't think i really did
understand that last part that you that
if i was understanding you you're what
you're saying is that you use
some part of the special education
for something beyond what has been shown
on the on the
on the on the formula of the 3.5 over
3.5 times
times 80 is that correct no for our
maintenance of effort that we
um have with the federal government for
our idea grant we
list she was just stating that we list
special education aid
and we list the 402 costs that go
forward so both of those go into
the the um and the maintenance of effort
that we have to file with them so
it wasn't that we used the funds it was
just i see
that we list the budgeted amounts yeah i
see okay no i now i understand thank you
very much
representative pucco oh thank you madam
chair
um can i can we go back one slide to the
formula
please and um
that's that's fine right there this is
probably right over my head but
how do we determine that the total 99
how do we arrive at that figure that's
what that is um
that's what we're saying that the
district spent on the student they spent
the ninety nine thousand four eight
hundred and forty five dollars on the
students
example in this example so that was just
so we just
took an example of what a district could
have okay
if that student incurred those costs of
99 845 what it would look like as it
played out
through the formula oh okay thank you i
thought that was something
a formula that was in statute or
something nope so
it just shows how that formula plays out
with these numbers
right representative bucco so how it
works for is so a school district will
go through
a year knowing a kid has an iep and
knowing what is in the kids iep
and recording the different expenses
that they are occurring associated with
that kid
so at the end of the year they have
caitlyn davis's iep
and it says all of the services that
caitlin davis received
and it has um the costs associated with
those services
that is submitted to the department of
education with a very thick stack of
invoices that
show that all of those services were
paid for and then
um becky and lisa and and bridget have a
whole team of staff that review
all of those invoices for the different
districts and determined that those
expenses were allowable and appropriate
for the child's iep
and they come up with a total determined
amount that is an allowable amount
that the state of new hampshire agrees
that was appropriate for that kid
so in this for this specific example
caitlyn davis may have had 120
20 120 000 worth of expenses associated
with her
some of them might be just related to
regular education so that would not be
allowable for submission and then maybe
caitlyn davis had reimbursement for a
service that the department of education
doesn't allow
maybe they reimburse the school had a
cost associated with me that maybe
wasn't my iep
as provided it but if it wasn't not in
my iep it's not eligible for
reimbursement
so at the end of the day per the review
of becky and her team they've decided
that caitlyn davis has 99
000 worth of expenses associated with me
then they say all right well how much
was the cap and they take the cap
which was fifty nine thousand dollars
three and a half times the average cost
for people and saying
the district would be responsible for
that forty thousand dollars and then we
put it through the formula that is
the statutory formula okay
yes thank you very much i i i was just i
i did um i didn't know if that 99 was
um an imposed cap or something but it's
new yeah this is
an example thank you
petry you have a question yes madam
chair thank you
uh i just i heard uh 402 mention that's
court appointed uh
placements uh could you explain that a
little bit
say i don't want to say something wrong
now i'm a little gun-shy
so court order works a little bit
different than special education aid so
a court order
is um three times the estimated cost per
pupil
and and it works again it works
different so
once the student reached cap then the
district submits invoices to us and then
and we pay however much is submitted to
us there's no cap
on how much we paid to the district for
court ordered placements
there's no timeline so they could submit
a student
from the previous year or two years ago
and we would still pay it and it's in
oh so and so if there's it's there's an
rsa that if they're
left over on special education aid funds
that it gets put into um the court order
funds
to be paid out each year each year
yes thank you can i just ask can you
just tell us
generally is is the
is the issue of you know is this is this
a
has has the law as the local district
properly categorized um
special education expenses or not
properly categorize them
is that something that you know is sort
of a
an ongoing issue of contention between
the state department and districts or
or is that run sort of pretty smoothly
um i would say that it's pretty smooth
that's the process that we talked about
where caitlin mentioned we have a team
of
um people who come in and they review
all of the invoices
um and then what happens yep and they
they look at the invoices that are sent
to us and they look at the iep
and they if there are questions we
always seek um clarification from the
district but the
the invoices need to match up with what
is in the iep and what the team has
determined
uh could you give us an example if um
let's say i i have um a severe
speech problem okay and uh
could you give us an example of and
that's what my iep is for
could you give an example of what
might not be
agreeable in that case so the only
things that would not be
um approved allowable are things that
are not within the iep
so if you had a speech person and and
and they submitted for
um something that was not listed in the
iep say they listed three services per
week
for that speech person and then they
asked us for reimbursement for five
services a week
we would say no because it doesn't align
with what the iep states
it states that you're gonna provide
three we're going to reimburse you for
those three
um that might be an example typically
they don't ask for anything really
extraneous but it but it does need to
okay are there any other questions
seeing none i'm sure that everyone will
pour through how much
uh your town received but that's okay
so thank you rebecca we uh we appreciate
it
and um i'm i think that it has provided
some uh
good knowledge for all of us so thank
you
so caitlyn um do you want to
uh so
our next speaker um is eric froworth who
is the executive
uh representative petrie had a question
oops okay um yes thank you
uh i guess the now i forgot to question
um the oh the i know what it was
the uh the slides that you just uh
um presented uh are they gonna be
available are they gonna be sent to us
um i sent them to the lba and i believe
mickey has posted them
already okay uh joe mickey had indicated
earlier that he has
uh already put them
in uh an envelope and
mailed them to us so okay very good okay
they have been emailed to everybody last
night i emailed them pdf
they're posted on online as well and the
committee is getting hard copies
i need a mickey too he's very helpful
um all right so next up we have eric
froworth so eric falworth is the
administrator of our current tech
education
bureau which oversees some of our
federal and state career tech education
funding
including career and tech education
tuition and transportation which is a
line-up
item in the education trust fund eric
good morning thanks caitlin good morning
everyone uh for the record i'm eric
froworth i'm the administrator of the
bureau of career development
and i am actually in my home office in
see if i can make this work
okay are you i'm assuming you are all
seeing my screen now
yes we are wonderful thank you uh
all right so as part of uh our funding
for career and tech education
uh there is a line item referred to as
uh tuition and transportation
and this tuition and transportation is
exclusively
reimbursement for uh cte
students who are attending programs
outside of their district
uh so i need to make sure that's very
clear that for example manchester
has multiple high schools and if
students are attending
manchester west but then travel to mst
for cte
that those costs are not included as
part of this those are completely
locally
uh subsidized uh transportation costs
so it is only for students sending
schools sending students to out of
district korean tech education centers
the transportation portion is reimbursed
to the sending school
they outlay the money for transportation
and they are reimbursed
the tuition portion is reimbursed
directly to the cte center
so the money goes from two different
places it is reimbursed each year
on or before december 1st for the
previous year
so this past december we just reimbursed
the schools
for the previous year's tuition
as detailed in ed rule 1305
the transportation portion is reimbursed
first
from the fund and then the remaining
dollars
are utilized to reimburse up to 75
percent
of the tuition cost if
there is not sufficient funds to
reimburse the full 75 percent of the
tuition cost
then the total remaining is divided by
the number of eligible students
and a set amount per student is sent to
the schools
prior to 2014 it was done proportionally
but the rule was changed in 2014 so it
is just a flat amount per student
that is then distributed to each of the
so excuse me before you go on absolutely
is the is the school dist is the sending
school district then responsible
for the difference between what the
state provides
and what they have identified as the
cost
yes so uh the initially the school the
sending school district
will pay 25 with the state paying up to
once the full cycle comes through if the
is not available the sending school
uh thank you you're very welcome
uh so the next few slides are for uh
more for informational purposes for you
that you'll see when you have the
packets
uh we've included a map to show where
all of the schools are
and this map includes not only our cte
centers but also the community colleges
that are affiliated with career and tech
programs
so the different colors are the regions
so each
high school in a region is assigned to a
cte center
so you can see how the distribution is
amongst our 20 regions
five of those regions are in vermont
because our high schools are actually
closer to vermont cte centers
than they are to new hampshire-based
ones
so our students travel over to vermont
for their cte programs
and in that case the new hampshire
school
pays the full tuition and then they are
reimbursed from the state so those are
the only instances where
the sending school is reimbursed for the
tuition from the state because we do not
send our
uh representative heath you had a
question i'm sorry
that's okay i do indeed um cte
is such a magnificent program um
and i'm i'm happy to hear that um we did
try
and increase the funding during the last
session
but it still troubles me that we did not
we weren't able to fully
fund the tuition and transportation
so the school districts didn't get that
full amount um
tell me about your numbers i'm on an
international
committee with ncsl and we're really
talking about the importance and the
need to really fully expand
cte programs how are our numbers
enrollments across the state are they
increasing
are we seeing more students or just
what's happening sure no thank you for
asking uh and yes
um although as you're probably aware our
high school population numbers are
decreasing
our cte numbers are actually increasing
um
we're close to a total of about 10 000
students participating in cte each year
um and and so that number you know this
this year is a little strange
for a variety of reasons but we
we have been watching our cte numbers
increase
and we are still we are attempting to
continue that increase
actively uh trying to find ways to
increase those numbers
madam chair if i could just ask a
follow-up please certainly
um that was great um that and that's
good news um
tell me about kyle perkins funding has
that
risen um and is it helping you in your
efforts
or where are we now in terms of federal
funding for
c c t e centers yes so
uh that also is rising so we're very
happy with that as well
in our our current year's allocation is
uh
just over 6.1 million dollars and we
just received our estimate for next year
which will be 6.5 million
uh so federally uh they are working on
increasing it
um there is a push to double it
at the federal level um we're very
hopeful because our new
um newly added secretary of education
is a cte graduate great uh
so we are very excited and he is a
community college graduate as well so
we're very excited about the opportunity
that
uh he might increase that funding uh but
yes um
so it is 6.5 million dollars that is
allocated to our schools
that provide a large supplement and
that's what the intention is
if on the off chance perkins disappeared
the intent is that our cte program
should still be able to maintain
and continue so the perkins is used for
add-ons new additional equipment etc
thank you yeah um i i
appreciate the fact that um
cte student enrollment is increasing
but i am very distressed
about the fact that the sending school
enrollment is not
necessarily doing as well as
i think it should and so
um what what are
is the state doing anything to
help that uh
thank you for asking we we are actively
working on this uh we have just come we
had hired last year
a consultant to work with us to dig deep
into that question
they've just finished their report
there were a couple of typos that were
being fixed and it will be published
this week actually
up on our website and distributed uh
through a press release
we found that about 75 of the students
participating in cte are from the host
high schools
um now the fact that they're only there
are 28 host high schools
and well over a hundred school districts
in the state
there you can obviously there's a
disconnect there somewhere
and so we are uh part of the
the consultant's work was to now go okay
what were the issues why are students
from sending schools not participating
and start working with our regional cte
centers and our school districts
to combat those issues and find out
what's the best way to get more students
enrolled
we have multiple options um based on the
challenges
and we're about to start working with
some of our cte districts to figure it
out
um would you mind
uh sending that or sending that study to
mickey so that we
he can forward it to us because
absolutely
for i live in a
area where we don't have any sending
students
and everyone that attends our
high school has the opportunity to
to participate in cte but that's
not the norm and uh
so i just i just need to i need to dig
into this a little bit more because it
it may be
maybe you know obviously not for this
year but maybe for next year
we might need to change some
legislation to uh to try to
even out the um
attendance at ctes
thank you i'm happy to provide whatever
information i can as part of that
conversation
thank you uh representative murray
thank you madam chair and apologies for
being late that bill went way longer
than it should have especially since it
passed unanimously
but everyone has to talk um i'm maybe
jumping the gun
with all your students will you be going
over areas of study you know areas that
are particularly appealing to
the different students that are coming
to you thank you
coming along so thank you uh i can
certainly talk about that and actually
the next
two pages in my presentation and that
you'll have in your packet
uh is the grid uh that we publish it's
also on our website
that will it lists across the top let me
shrink this just a little tiny bit
uh it lists across the top all of our
sending all of our centers
and then down the left hand side uh it
lists all of our programs of study
uh and they're broken into 16
large categories so for example in the
agriculture food and natural resources
we have assorted agricultural programs
environmental studies
forestry animal sciences all fit in that
large broad category
uh and then uh and then it just works
its way down
our construction arts and technology
business education finance
government health science hospitality
human services
which in new hampshire is strictly
cosmetology
i.t law public policy
security manufacturing marketing stem
and transportation uh and so
each of our centers has a different mix
of programs
those programs are locally based so
each for every four years a school must
conduct a local needs assessment
uh where it is determined what uh
the needs of that local community are
to that could support the cte programs
the perkins funds
are very specific in that they are only
eligible for programs
that are high skill high need
high wage and so programs must fit into
one of those categories
uh and i hate to use the example because
i do come
from a from an art artsy background a
theater program for example
in new york city would be eligible for
cte funds because
there's obviously a community for it in
new hampshire we have a couple of them
but we cannot add additional programs
because new hampshire as a community
will not support 75 graduates every year
in theater arts
we just don't have the economy to
support that
so that's part of the local needs
assessment to make sure that we can
manufacturing health science
auto tech are very popular programs in
new hampshire
they're very well supported by the
industries in new hampshire
we could theoretically open a health
science program at every center
and not produce enough graduates to meet
the health industry needs
our auto programs similarly fill up
consistently
our students work hand in hand with the
local dealership associations and all
walk right into
jobs or they can then continue on to the
community college
uh representative murray you have a
question
no i'm so sorry just distracted forgot
put my hand down so sorry apologies
you don't you don't have to apologize
we all have these problems okay i do
have a couple of
questions um on the
careertech advisory boards for
schools that receive students from other
areas are there
advisory board members from the
sending schools uh
yes so each uh there are two separate
types of advisory boards at the cte
centers
there's the regional advisory board
which is at the center level and that is
made up of representatives from all of
the sending districts
so it uh ideally is somebody from
the school as well as somebody from the
school board
and then large employers from the entire
region
and that is the group that looks at the
school as a whole
talks about what types of programs
should be offered at the school
as well as works on recruitment
opportunities for the students from the
sending schools
each of the programs then also has an
advisory board
made up of industry industry people from
the entire region
okay so the sending schools are in fact
represented on the regional board
they are okay thank you
and when the four-year study is done
um do they look at communities
outside of where the career tech center
is located
uh in other words out to the sending
schools
yes the local needs assessment is for
their entire catchment region
so as you saw on that map
uh so for example this this is concord's
region they have sent they have students
coming from high schools in all of these
towns so their regional advisory board
is made up of
representatives from all of those
sending communities and their local
needs
assessment is because that's where those
students will be going back to work
okay thank you very much yes um
and and they may also extend beyond that
you know we
we look at depending on the region
if they're looking for a new program we
we can take into account
average drive time if somebody is you
know averaging 20 to 30 minute drive
time
what are the job opportunities within
that catchment area to offer
a program thank you
yes and so for example our newest
program that we
just launched is aviation um and that is
because the faa
actually approached us that they have a
large need over the next 10 years for
employees
and so we have launched this year one
we will have possibly two additionals
that add next year
and we have three more schools backing
up beyond that to add aviation
uh and then we will be working on i will
i recreation management as the next one
yeah i will say that the uh aviation
program
that we have here in in conway
has been extremely popular
and i'm sure that it as it is brought
online in other areas that
um that it will be as popular so
it's a good thing you you are that your
school is the lead they uh
they hit the ground running um and uh so
they
they've become the sort of the gold
standard for our programs uh but you are
yes you you have no sending students so
your students are eligible
everyone in the building learns about
okay so uh the next chart in here
uh goes back um just over 10 years i
guess to 11 12 years
uh it lists each town
that has received tran travel uh tuition
or transportation money
so as you go through the list at home
you may find that there are completely
missing
towns and that could be because
uh even if they obviously have students
from there they may not have a high
school
so therefore their students are
attending a different town's high school
so that town's high school is the one
that is receiving the reimbursement for
the travel
um and so it just
lists all the way down of for each each
town
what their the amount is and all the way
down at the bottom you'll see it totals
down to the nine million dollars
and then the following chart is the
breakdown of each town and whether
they have a tuition payment
and some will have both um any school
that sends to vermont
will have both again because they they
pay the tuition full tuition and have
reimbursed
but then also several of our towns like
claremont
claremont is in a region where there are
two cte centers
one in claremont and one in newport and
so
claremont could be ascending school if
they're sending students to the
cosmetology program
in newport and they are also a receiving
school
that students from
newport and the other surrounding towns
send students to claremont so they will
receive tuition
and so this just shows how the money was
each year the cte centers will provide
to our office the cost of a cte
education
so it is a percentage of the total
student cost for education
it ranges between 20 and 40 percent uh
many centers just pick one as an
all-encompassing comprehensive
but schools like dover you can see they
have
a very wide variety of programs they
again it is between 20 and 40 percent uh
so that is the tuition number that
they'll put on the av-1 form
that they submit to us per semester
comes up with what the total
tuition will be for the year and then
there's then the number of students that
attended cte for the year
and uh you will notice that we do have
percentage of students
uh because the stude if a student only
attends for part of the year we only pay
for that part of the tuition
so they report attendance three times
over the course of the semester
so if a student only tends for for a
part of that semester
then we won't pay the full tuition for
the full semester they didn't attend
so we do have partial students
uh multiplies across um and
so theoretically berlin um
would have received for 75 tuition
reimbursement of 115
962 however
um based on the the amount available
there was only 77 000 available
so that 38 000
was short and they would then be sending
bills out to their sending schools to
make up that difference so the sending
school will get a secondary
uh you will notice there are some
positive numbers
because of the way the formula
allocation happens
conval for example 75
of their tuition cost is 2 800
the tuition payment based on the formula
allocation was just over three thousand
dollars per student
so they actually came into black
five thousand dollars at the end of the
year
uh it's the rare occasion uh several
schools like you'll see exeter
with short 382 thousand dollars i'll say
they
had to go back to their school districts
excuse me uh representative murray you
have a question
yep i do just clarification so the
request for funds that goes back to the
community um
is that something that would eventually
be paid for with an increase in property
taxes
uh i won't talk to that i don't know
where that
might come from uh school districts
typically have a line item in their
budget
uh that are sending schools that they've
allocated a specific amount of money
from their school budget
to send to the cte centers for tuition
all right thank you
yes representative heath you have a
question
thank you madam chair just a quick one
do you think
eric that the cost to the sending
schools
in their budget is ever a deterrent
to attending the regional center
we have heard it i do not have
definitive fact but from
the um consultants that did come up
that school districts it's a
conversation school districts have
i will tell you that um we're happy to
fight that conversation anytime because
legislatively
the law states that any student who
wants to go can attend
so if a student applies and is accepted
into a cte center
the school district under the law cannot
we've never heard somebody say no i've
never heard of a school district you
know a student saying i wanted to go and
they wouldn't let me
but conversations with our consultants
were that
um the cost does come up as part of
school district budget conversation for
sure
uh mary i i think the the bigger problem
is not is not the cost but the fact that
the children that are going
to the consolidated cte centers
are losing out on some amount
of educational
whatever every day that they're
attending the cte and
i don't know how we um i know we can't
crack that in the budget
but we may be able to um
work on something that
i i don't know but it that's always been
the big
uh the big problem with uh with
people kids going to uh to the ctes
around the states we'll see
madam chair if i may please
i agree with you and um it's the lost
time
that kids have when they have to ride
the buses but i really hope that we can
figure out something because i think
it's a loss
and we need those areas desperately
in our employment environment
so i hope we can do something thank you
representative murray you still had your
hand up
mistake again i'm sorry i'm still
distracted i'll do better
i promise don't don't worry about it
uh thank you and uh yes uh in our study
that that was a big piece is the travel
time
and the lost um or the schedule conflict
that a student is in
you know ap english at nine in the
morning and it's the only time their
school offers it and so they cannot take
the bus
to go to the cte center at the same time
we part of our conversations with our
cte centers and our sending schools will
be around embedded credits
to find out if there are opportunities
that the students can earn those
other credits while they are taking
their cte classes to eliminate some of
that missed class time
but that is a a very complicated
conversation amongst nine sending school
uh so with the with this tuition um
if the state would have fully funded the
75 percent
um including uh plus the alt-ed tuition
which is also a small amount included in
here
and the transportation uh would have
been a total of almost 12 million
dollars
uh which would would be a shortfall of
uh just shy of three million dollars if
um and that's based on the current
transportation formula which is what i
will talk about next
oh so i'm sorry so the um this past year
the
tuition rate was three thousand six
hundred and seventeen dollars per
student
was what was uh when it was divided by
the twenty
500 students that are taking part in cte
so the transportation cost per
um education rules for transportation
the schools are reimbursed
which you'll note the bus cost the same
whether there are 10 students on it or
40 students on it but we re that is the
regulation as they are reimbursed at 10
cents per mile per student
so this form will show what the school
districts reported their cost was for
the busing
and what was actually reimbursed for the
busing
and so the total cost of busing to send
students to cte
was 2.6 million dollars based on the
formula of 10 cents per mile per student
so in addition to the 3 million dollar
shortfall from the tuition
if we were to fully fund transportation
it would be an additional 2 million
dollars so
we're now hitting a five million dollar
shortfall
of fully funding tuition and
transportation
so we do have legislation in this year
to change the regulations so that
transportation is fully funded
however it does not increase the total
in the budget
so transportation will be fully funded
up front
and then that leftover money is divided
amongst the school the sending
the students so it just lowers the
amount available for tuition and the
schools
get hit with that secondary tuition
so we borrowed from peter to pay paul
but we didn't want transportation to be
the reason that a school wasn't sending
a student that they were spending so
much on transportation
okay so did it has that passed the
legislature already
oh it is currently um in uh it is in our
cte bill that is working its way through
the legislature
okay so it hasn't finished it has not
gone anywhere yet
okay so that
will probably take effect later on
outside the budget cycle correct it
would be next year
okay thank you well next year's in the
budget cycle right
it would be well it would it would take
effect
we just wouldn't unless this year's
budget money is increased
the schools for the next two years will
be reimbursed fully for busing
and end up having to pay more for
tuition
and that is the end of my slide so i'm
open for other questions if there are
any
uh does anyone have any additional
questions for eric
we appreciate your uh very much
what uh i did have one one other point
and um
becky reminded me of it when she did
hers uh
this nine million dollars is also part
towards the perkins grant towards our
uh representative heath oh thank you
madam chair
and thank you eric um again
this is used for maintenance of effort
do you have enough
or what else do you use for that
sure so i actually have a maintenance of
effort
chart
i'm assuming you're seeing this now new
yes we are okay uh so
um so our maintenance of effort is
any state monies that goes towards
cte so salaries for all the staff in my
office
all of the you know office expenses
our membership dues for our
national membership for ctes is part of
our is a state fund
any travel that we do in state and then
this nine million dollars
and so based on this uh for this current
year for fy21
uh assuming all of our you know
we're assuming twelve thousand dollars
in state travel which we may not
actually do this year because we didn't
travel a lot
we are anticipating that we will
surpass our moe requirement by about 145
thousand dollars
so we just make it if we do not
meet our moe for our perkins
our perkins funds next year would be
reduced by the amount we miss
and we are responsible for repaying the
federal government for the difference
that we missed so we get hit twice
so um i have a phenomenal ba
who works this chart to make sure that
we do not miss our moe
um and so she has actually put it out
several years
based on anticipated raises etc in
salaries
um and so we're looking at
next year of a possible shortfall
but that really depends on where we land
this year
because if we don't spend quite as much
this year we're okay as long as we meet
our moe
but she's keeping an eye on it for us
and so that's something that we'll keep
yeah eric maybe you could uh send this
little chart to
us since it didn't come yes
uh representative petrie you have a
question
yes thank you madam chair uh the uh
are we gonna expand cte or or
within the facilities we have now or
are we going to have more one of the
things
when i was on the farmington school
board we actually changed uh centers we
went to wolfeboro
versus tri-city and uh
you know it's it we found that our kids
were spending more time on the bus and
uh so we are we're looking at all
options um
we are looking at how we can
offer cte programs at non-regional
centers
um the challenge being student
population and critical mass
uh you know uh were we we would not
be offering an auto program at every
high school that just cost wise doesn't
make sense
but um what i refer to as the more
didactic programs the business-based
programs the computer-based programs
most high schools have facilities that
could run those programs
the question is would you have enough
students at every high school
to run that program and so that's where
this consultant is
going to come in handy for us to try to
figure out what the best way is to
and it may mean setting up regional
programs
at more comprehensive high schools so a
student
you know if they were looking to do a
business program they only have to
travel to the next town over
so it's less travel time but then that
ends up being more travel costs for the
school district because now they have
two buses that they're sending uh so
we're trying to balance all of those and
figure out
uh the answer we don't know the answer
massachusetts had decided on the model
of regional cte high schools
where if you wanted to go you just
transferred to that high school you went
for four years
and then that alleviated all of these
challenges well they've now
maxed out those high schools and they
have wait lists
so now they're trying to figure out now
what do we do and our
cte programs are popping up at more high
schools
having the same problem we have how do
we get more students involved
so we're looking at all the model
options there may be more options like
mst
where there is a four-year high school
that's showing up and students will just
transfer there
vermont has a model where a student can
spend the entire day at the cte center
and complete a program in one year so
that way
they can the schedule problem isn't as
bad they just go for the whole day and
then go back but it's only one year so
they'll go for their 10th grade or their
11th grade year
out of high school and that's it so
we're looking at all different models
absolutely
okay thank you uh very much eric and uh
caitlyn what kind of great things do you
have next
for us okay so next up
we have amy clark um so amy clark has a
variety of different topics to talk to
you about today
um i don't know what you guys want to do
as far as breaks or whatnot obviously
we're going to come back
after lunch but what do you guys
typically break at 12 or 12 30
oh we figure it out depending upon
depending upon what's what's what's
going on
all right so amy the first the first
topic she so just three topics
um building aid which is a fairly
complex
topic i think you know every time amy
gets into that the committee has a lot
of questions so
i would say that might be go until up
until lunch and then she can do her two
quicker topics after lunch maybe that
planning wise we can see how that goes
or maybe building a little stretch
but so amy um we'll be talking about
building aid and
then also the public school
infrastructure fund and
thank you for having me um so again my
name is amy clark
and for the record i work for the
department of education for the bureau
of state safety and facility management
so good to see you and especially
representative umberger it's so good to
see you back
um and some friendly faces so that's
always uh eases the pain of having to
talk to a committee when you know a
couple of the faces of the crowd
uh but here is not that this is painful
at all
of course for us um so
here is a summary of the building aid
program
and in my pocket i have these six things
that will go over some of them
more at length and some of them just so
that you have them for your insurance
um i have a summary of the building aid
program i've been building a rates
i have a tail graph and a list of the
applications as well as a list of the
current payments that we're making
and a list of um some other projects
i'm not seeing your screen yet have you
started putting it i
have i am sorry about that let's see
so there's my contact information right
there
and you should have all of these
handouts but here is
um there's a one-page summary of the
program because my name my
contact information if you ever have
some more detailed questions you want
answered
uh the law and the rules are cited there
as well
so simply put building aid is grant
funds to support local school districts
in meeting the cost of construction or
reconstruction
that is the source the state funds that
they use
to tap into are building aid grants
the grants typically are the grants
range from 30 to 60 percent that's the
state
share of those grants with less affluent
communities being at the 60 percent more
affluent communities being at the 30
percent
um i'd just like to notice that note
that even though the range is 30 to 60
the actual average rate is closer to the
range so it's weighted the formula is
weighted so the average community
gets 38 um the funding source is now the
education trust fund which caitlyn
mentioned
um so um the
way that grants are paid to schools uh
it's important to
cover because we're going to talk about
the tail or these obligated payments so
keep in mind during the presentation
that there's two types
of ways that building aid has been
funded
building aid has been around since the
1940s all the way up through 2012
the law said that building aid was going
to be
paid over the life of a bond so as well
without a 20-year bond
building aid would be paid every year on
the
like on the term of the month during
their bonding
in 2013 the law was changed
and it the law in 2013 now says
that the state pays 80 percent of that
grant amount
before construction and 20
upon completion so instead of making
payments over 20 years
now building it only makes two payments
just two
and that's it one eighty percent up
front and then 20
upon completion so for a quick example
if a school district had a 20-year bond
and let's say their school costs to
construct it
40 million dollars and let's say for
example for easy numbers their building
aid rate was 50
the state is going to pay 20 million and
the local
share is going to be 20 million so prior
to 2013
that grant amount that state grant
amount of 20 million
would have been paid out in 1 million
every year for 20 years
after if that project happened after
that project would have been paid 16
million up front that's the 80
so 60 million dollars up front before
they even start construction
and then 4 million upon completion
um and so when we were paying
on the term of a bond those are called
obligated payments and if you can think
about it it was a 20-year bond
is a common example um we do have a
couple of 30-year bonds but for the most
part a 20-year bond is pretty
typical that means we are still paying
on projects that are
20 years old or just finishing up those
payments
um so we'll get back to that in a little
bit more but that's the kind of the
summary of the funding structure of
building
here's a little bit of the history that
you'll have it's a short history here
but
um building it again has been around
since the 1940s
and as um money was
has been appropriated to meet demand
all the way up till um about 2007.
and so uh there are keep in mind
money was appropriated to meet demand so
schools came to the department of
education
they proposed a construction project we
collected okay this is going to cost you
this much
we're going to pay you this much we've
reported it to the legislature
and the legislature appropriated enough
money to cover
um what schools needed now that doesn't
mean they could put in a swimming pool
and it doesn't mean they can put an
athletic turf deal
in there were caps on building aid there
are still cats on what is eligible
what's not
those eligible costs they could report
hey i need um
you know we're expanding or um you know
this
wall is falling down and those are the
in 2008 and 2009 we all remember
there was quite a difficult um time at
that
time um financially and so
so we did not the state did not have
enough money to pay those obligated
funds so i had passed projects
but we could not meet those payments and
payments were
diminished so we asked the legislature
for so much money and and they didn't
um um appropriate as much as the schools
needed
and therefore payments were prorated to
about 95
so not significant shortfall but a
shortfall in london
in 2010 there was even more of a
significant shortfall
and what happened in 2010 is the state
was paying
about 49 million dollars per year
each year on obligated payments
and what the state said is we can't meet
that obligation
but we want to make the payments so the
state
took out their own bond to pay the
obligated payments
um i see some people shaking their heads
so that's probably the appropriate
response i think most people would
have that response um so what that means
is that they took out a bond
to pay schools on their bond
um that keep in mind that that practice
um is now prohibited by law um
shortly after somebody said this takes
on how to do that anymore
but either way it was done in 2010 and
that
created a 20 it was a 20-year bond that
created a 20-year bond
off for those obligated payments and
we'll see that show up a little bit
later
too but that happened in 2010.
what also happened in 2010 is
house bill 2 put an official moratorium
on school building aid for two years
state said
that we'll fund those obligated payments
from past projects
but from here on out for the next two
years we are not going to pay on any new
school construction projects and
um two years went by and then in 2012
2013 that next biennium that moratorium
was
extended for another two years also what
happened
in 2013 um the
building aid laws were rewritten
somewhat
significantly the key things that they
did in 2013
um was that they put a cap or the
legislation
now has a path on building aid
and it says that there shall not be any
the appropriation shall not be
any larger than 50 million dollars per
year and that exists today
where there is a cap on building aid of
50 million dollars
per year and what that cap
what that cap did was it now created
instead of being able to fund
on demand it created a ranking and a way
that the department of education has to
decide
how to give that money out well it
wasn't a problem in 2012 and 2013
because we were
still in a moratorium and that
moratorium actually lasted for 10 years
so from 2014 to 2019
there were no new projects um because of
the moratorium
in um rsa 19850
in the building aid law and so
although the law was changed in 2013 it
really didn't have an impact
because we did not have any funds to
actually award schools
in um 2018 there is one
exception and in 2018 um
pennsdale elementary school was in some
of an emergency
and so the legislature opened up
building a just for hinsdale elementary
school
for that fun project um so aside from
that the state stayed in that moratorium
in 2020 in 2021 our current
biennium the moratorium officially ended
and by that i mean i was still too no
longer said that there was a moratorium
on building the appropriation
for fiscal 20 was the max amount of 50
million dollars so for the first time
ever
in 2020 the state appropriated
the full 50 million dollars of building
aid
and in 2021 um the state appropriates 39
million dollars
uh ability and there's probably a couple
of reasons that that wasn't 50 million
um well one another 11 million dollars
but also because there is a list of
projects
and the amount that was appropriated
was enough to cover three of the five
projects that applied
and three of the five projects that
applied
um well i should say the bottom two
projects that
that were not funded had um not
passed their warrant full um and
matter of fact they didn't the
subsequent year either um
and so there may have been maybe that
was one of the reasons
all i know is i was able to fund the top
three project
those top three projects of that 50
million
and 39 million for the biennium
that included all my obligated payments
lost 8.6 million dollars for these three
projects
8.6 million dollars of grant money for
three projects these projects were
relatively small
um so there's that summary page again
a lot on all that page um but that's
here are the rates if you're curious as
to hey what does my town get or what
other towns get this is um you'll have
this in your packet and it's just
a list of the building aid rates those
rates are recalculated
every year but they are based on median
median family income and equalized
valuation per pupil
what is great about the formula
as somebody who has to calculate it it
is a ranking
of those the ranking of median family
income
and the ranking of equalized valuation
per pupil
over a five year period so what that
helps schools
is because it's ranked media family
income sometimes people say
well it's not really all that accurate
i've heard before well this is a
ranking so it doesn't necessarily matter
if it's perfectly accurate
or keeps that snapshot if if media
family income
goes down in a certain area sometimes
everybody's goes down and their rankings
don't change a whole lot
so what happens with this formula is you
might see somebody is at 45
they are likely going to be at 45 this
year as well
and and so forth some of them do jump
categories but not
for the most part that those rates are
pretty steady
for planning purposes that help schools
out a lot having a steady formula like
that
um so you have that in your package and
then
five
on page five um you should have
um of this graph
and on this graph um
i won't spend a little bit of time on
this track because i think it's um
helpful it
kind of tells you a little bit of the
story about where we're going
uh for building a the
y-axis is in millions so that y-axis
conveniently goes from zero to 50
million
the x-axis is fiscal years so if you
recall
i said uh funding was fully funded in
principle 20 you can see that bar goes
all the way up to 50 million the bottom
now how that's broken out is the bottom
dark blue bar
this bottom one here are the obligated
payments
that are given to those past projects
those bonds are out there they're for
all projects that are already built
that's the second column of data in your
table here the second called
obligated payment systems
that light blue bar the one on the top
solid bar
is that 2010 bond payment if you recall
i said it was a 20-year bond payment you
can see our last
payment is fiscal 2030.
that's date bond to pay those obligated
payments from
2010. that is the third column
and you can see in 2030 we'll make our
last payment the state will make their
last payment and that would be done
dark blue bar to schools the light blue
bar
is that 2010 bond unit
these little dashed lines uh are the
payments that were uh for new projects
for the first time
uh at least in over 10 years so here's
the new projects here
6.7 million uh in the first year of the
biennium
1.9 million in the second year of the
biennium those
those new funds funded three projects
which
free rate um
also amy yeah amy before you go on
it shows the dark blue as obligated
what are those those are the bond
payments on past construction projects
so
um yeah yep i got it
30 million basically
due off the the bonding that we did in
2010 is that correct
um so in 2010
um if you could see do you see this can
you see my cursor
uh on your end you guys so
in 2022 this um biennium coming up
2022 the state will have an 8.1 million
dollar
payment on that 2010 bond
um we'll own 27 million schools
for those past projects we'll have that
eight point one million dollar bond
uh payment payment and then that total
okay thank you very much so this is not
this is not
new funding this is old funding that
we're paying down
correct yep so the all of those solid
bars are all just past
those are those are projects that are
already done thank you
you're welcome and so the total of those
so let's see
um the total of so we're coming up
let me focus on fiscal um
one two two and twenty three since
that's the one individual like it's done
right here
if you can see the total of my obligated
payments to schools plus that 2010 bond
totals 35 million and we can see that on
the ground
if you look under crystal 22 there's the
obligation
there's the 2010 bond and if you see
right there that's 35 million
so we are going to be paying 35 million
as long as it's appropriated
in that manner um the second year in the
biennium that'll go down a little bit to
32 million
you can see why it's called the tail
it's like a tail
but it looks like that because every
year we continue to pay off projects
that are you know we're making our final
payment to somebody this year
and those projects that were built 28
years ago i'll no longer have to pay
them
um if you um
move over to the 50 million dollar
column it says 50 million
less debt service what this column
represents
is if building aid were fully funded
and when i say fully funded i mean up to
the maximum extent of the law
of 50 million dollars per year what this
would allow
is this much money for new projects
um so if buildings were fully funded in
22 and 23
it would give 15 million the first year
the biennium
and 18 million and the second year of
the biennium for a new construction
project
that's what would be available for new
construction projects
that total for the biennium has shipped
these two numbers added together
uh yeah the debt
service is um
uh maybe let me think about that but
uh i'm not i'm not
convinced that um
that i know it comes out
of the education trust fund i got that
but i'm not sure that we
need to look at it as reducing
the amount that's available for
new construction but i'll have to i'll
have to
that's actually a good question um caleb
you want me to answer that or you look
like you can answer it yeah okay
she's my boss so i'll defer to her if
she wants but um representative umberger
um you are for i'm glad you're thinking
like that
uh that would free up a little bit more
money for new construction projects
at one time that is how the law was
interpreted
and we would take 50 million and
subtract
out our just our obligated payments but
i believe
three years ago caitlin correctly had
around
three years ago um if um somebody else
had a different interpretation
and said that we had to include those
debt service payments
um in that 50 direction
but somebody has looked at it and
changed sort of how we
look at that representative
we had a legal interpretation from the
ag's office
and they determined that um i do want to
just clarify too that the debt service
is actually not in the education trust
fund only the
obligated schools to payment so like
that true tale
that is the portion that's an education
trust and the remaining amount i believe
is
in the treasury's portion of the budget
but like you can yeah
i think you're right it is yeah so these
two pieces are in different places right
the education trust fund is here
and treasury is here um however for me
or for other schools when they're
looking at funding new projects i have
to include both as the total debt
service
less than 50 million uh therefore that
would give me a resolving
32 million dollars for new projects if
building a work fully funded
in fiscal 22 and 23. and can i can i
point something out real quick
uh house bill 594 which passed the house
at the end of february um is referred to
finance
and that bill and amy can speak more to
it but
that bill turns that 50 million dollar
ceiling into a floor
so that's where these two years where
amy is doing the 50 million dollar
exercise
comes into play this committee will have
to consider that bill
thank you matt representative petry
yes madam chair thank you uh looking at
the uh
20 and 21 at the uh on 20 you've got 6.7
million allocated for construction
projects
how come the 21 year doesn't show that
to the full 50 million
or is that just on the other part of the
chart show that
well that's a good question so that 13
million that you're seeing there
was if building a were fully funded to
50 million
building it was not fully funded it was
uh only funded to 39 million
um that year instead of 50 million so
that's why there's 13 million
this is what the legislature could have
appropriated but they did not
they did not appropriate 19.2 million
for the biennium
instead they appropriated 8.6
it's 6.7 in fiscal 2020
um which is there so it was fully funded
there
but then this year was not fully funded
it's the only 1.9
instead of 13 million only 1.9 million
uh please unmute
okay i'm trying to get i'm
okay sorry um
so my question was uh uh
the chart shows um the blue
the dark blue is obligated payments and
plus the
the the light blue is the what was what
was bonded but but
all of the blue equals the tail
that that's called the tail right and it
does not it doesn't include the two
the two uh new construction amounts of
6.7 flips
point nine all right gotta know
correct and and and recall that those
payment those projects are now paid
differently
so since 2013 although it's 2013 we just
didn't have any
that was when the new law was in place
of how we paid projects
but in 2013 that law said we're no
longer going to have a tail
i'm going to fund all those projects so
when i said i paid 80 percent of the
project upfront
and so this 6.7 and 1.9
covers all payments for those three
projects
um and so those payments won't
won't drag on with this sale they're
done
and similarly if building it were fully
funded this 32 million
would be blips here if they would be
okay i'm going to spend this money i'm
going to give
projects to 32 million and we're not
going to talk about it in 2040 about how
much i have them
[Music]
thank you you're welcome yeah by the way
tom i think you voted for this
uh 80 20 split when uh
when we finally got it through the
legislature but
uh representative heath you have a
question yes thank you madam chair and
amy thank you
you do such a fabulous job explaining
all of this
my question is this
in the governor's budget we have 30
million dollars
dedicated to infrastructure would not
that be more useful if we took that 30
million
and put it in building aid and is that
too loaded a question to ask you
i'm working at home and caitlyn can't
even kick me under the desk
but i know uh no i am going to talk
about the public school infrastructure
fund so you'll see the differences
between
um the two funds and um that's really a
decision the public school
infrastructure fund
and school building aid are different
things
uh they have the word infrastructure in
them but they are different funding so
i'll present what public school
infrastructure fund is and you can
decide where that 30 million dollars
thanks uh
mary i i would agree that was a very
loaded question
and uh not not one that we should ask
amy to
um to answer but uh i can guarantee you
that we will be
debating that issue uh when
uh when we start doing our line by line
so thank you here i apologize no
problem tom or joe you have a question
yes thank you madam chair uh yeah no
it's not a question i just want to thank
the
members of the panel for uh great
presentation and i have to leave and i
reluctantly so you folks have a good day
and uh i wife's gonna have surgery so
i need to leave so thank you very much
okay amy uh do you have any other great
information for us
uh um i do but i think we've gone
through bulk of it even though
my number of slides won't tell that the
story but the rest of it is relatively
fast um here the next piece is the list
of the projects that have applied for
building aid this time around
so there is a biannual process for them
they have to apply
for this funding that potentially will
come or potentially not
um and this is a list of those projects
it is simply an
order of um sau um
so you can see it's hard to read them
it's more
for you to see the handout in front of
you but um
there's a description of the project
there's a list of the schools there's 12
of them
um their project offered here they're
building a rate
the total building eight amounts there
and then i added a column to show
where they are in their local local end
of things whether they're
already approved they're getting ready
for approval um
note that allen's town is going to vote
this um
march and their warrant article is
subject to receiving building aid
because
they have they are not going to be able
to fund this project i just want to
believe that that is the one that's
subject to building
a couple of schools have decided we're
not even going to vote on it
because we just don't know the status of
building it and we're going to wait two
years
some schools might also be waiting
because they're just undecided because
it's loaded what their school what their
future is
um so that's the reason and then there
are public schools that are passed
and they haven't done any construction
so they're they're eligible for billing
aid
but they're just holding off to see if
they um
get secured um so that there's a list of
the projects again
the summary is there but that really i
think this is maybe it's
the take-home message is that it's 270
million dollars worth of construction
they're seeking 104 million dollars of
state aid
if you recall from the graph if building
they were fully funded i would have 32
million dollars at most
in the biennium um so 104 million
dollars of projects seeking
uh money for construction could the law
currently attack
charge amy i i just have a question mary
will or
represent heath will uh if you don't
mind
uh i notice as i went down through there
uh that there were lots of people that
don't have
anything going to the voters for
a bond so the 104 million
could not possibly be spent
in this biennium is that correct
um no because i i shouldn't say spent
obligated
yeah it could because they would have so
um
they they could go next march because
it's a biannum
you know i i can offer so for example
um let's say this list is ranked it's
not but i would go to the top of the
list and i would offer
allentown 19 million dollars of their
building
um sorry for scrolling but i'm just
going to see what these numbers are
um this 32 million is 15 million in the
first year of the biennium
18 million in the second year again
that's assuming bill the gate were fully
funded to that 50 million
i would have 15 million in the first
year and 18 the second
so this is the list for both years so if
this were in order i would offer
i only have 15 but i'd offer 19 to allen
sound
uh they could they would get their
second piece of it the following
i really just need one of these projects
to pass and my money goes just like that
well i already know i mean i already
have a couple of schools
that have already passed i mean this
this is a 33 million dollar
rant award right here so the first year
the biennium
won't be a problem the second year of
the biennium getting an additional
amount of money
they start at the top of the list again
let's say allen's time did not pass but
they
would try again next march they could go
to vote next march
if they did pass they would then get
offered on that second year
um so this money will go because i have
more money
okay uh representative heath uh if you
would and then i'll
follow up with a question thank you
thank you madam chair
um amy we've had a number of projects
that were done previous to um
being being able to pay to any of the
school districts i think dover is one of
them
um am i correct
that those older projects are no longer
um available for funding it seems to me
that i think we passed a loss
some that said they weren't is that true
i i can't i'm just not sure
that's correct so if you built during
the moratorium um
essentially you have to be approved for
the va prior to construction
that's what the law says so if you build
without approval
which public school 594 it's not in
there right now that was removed from
household 594. it
comes up every two years to fund these
so uh amy you had indicated
that we had not spent all of the money
am i correct in that uh uh
you are correct i don't believe i said
that
but the the this amount of money
the 6.7 million um is
done and gone this 1.9 million was
when all said and done those three
projects
some of their costs were not eligible um
and therefore there is actually seven
hundred thousand dollars or so
that that will be returned that will
lapse back into the general fund or the
education trust fund
i don't know which way that gets um sent
back but
so yes technically those three projects
came under i won't say under budgets and
things were not eligible
and therefore seven hundred thousand
dollars would be free
but what i may have also said
is that of this 13 million dollars
building it was not fully funded
in fiscal 21 so 13 million
could have been if 50 million dollars
was appropriated but 50 million
was not appropriated only um
only 39 or so million dollars was
appropriated which must be only 1.9
million
so if i if i heard what you said
out of what was appropriated in the 2021
budget
that you have spent all that you had
okay and that will come back to us all
right thank you
and on a longer list i could offer that
700 000
to the next ranked project but my
project list only had five projects and
the bottom two did not pass their
local warrant articles so when you don't
have local approval you can't accept
building
which is important to remember because
some of these projects
might not pass their local approval
that doesn't mean i still give them
buildings obviously
okay different buildings they actually
have to have a contract
and that have state fire marshal's
office approval there's a lot of other
tools that they need prior to
so um page eight uh
you might want to avert your eyes
because i'm doing gonna do some
scrolling but um page 8 through 14
is just the payments um you can look on
any one of these
um these are the most obligated payments
and so this is fiscal 22 and 23 payments
that i'm making
um these are all those projects that
we've built in the past 20 years
um londonderry for example um
we there was an edition renovation put
on the south londonderry elementary
school
but um the project was about five
million dollars
their eight amounts a little over a
we paid that one this million dollars we
paid it
over that it was built in 2010 you can
see this was a
20 uh 20-year bond
so um from 2010 to 2029
we're paying them approximately 79 000
a year for 20 years um we
owe them 638 thousand dollars over the
course
until 2029 and we'll be done paying the
project
so here's a here's just all the projects
the complicated projects that you kind
of want to look to see
um if you're interested in what that
total tail is
that would be that dark blue bar if you
wanted to just be like word is going to
pay it off
uh all in one month some that um
total remaining payments is 163
million um in fy 20 we'll be paying that
26 million
uh and fy23 will became that one
both of those doctor bars
um let's see what else do i have here i
think this is
one of my last um things on building aid
um representative keith was
mentioning these projects that were
built during the moratorium
um well this is a list of projects that
i
know of that have built during the march
i would use this list cautiously
if there was ever talk of funding retro
projects
obviously i don't know anything about
these projects because they didn't
go through the department of education
because they did not receive building
aid but in the past 10 years during the
moratorium
these are the projects that are
committed i have no way of telling
whether they're eligible
if they they spent their money the way
they should have
um i'm sure they did um
but this is the total project class and
this was done
by surveys or sometimes i would read it
in a newspaper
and i would add it to the list so this
is not a fully vetted list
but it kind of gives you an idea of the
projects that are out there
their total costs uh they're their
building
rate if they were funded today they
didn't go back and
and take the specific year but this is
approximately what a great year
would have been and then they're
building a what would it
they did not receive buildings and big
years sometimes i have trouble figuring
out the year
and to be honest most of this was done
by a survey so most of this data i'd say
of this data was given to me by the
students themselves
um and on the bottom
you'll see if you're curious to know how
much construction went on
uh during moratorium um about
um 554 million dollars where the
projects were built without state
aid if we had granted state aid it would
have been supposed to
complete
and
[Music]
thank you amy are there any questions
that i mean we've asked a thousand of
them and so
uh i know that um we probably have a
thousand more but that's okay
so oh representative murray i'm sorry
you have
another question i just have to say that
was so totally clear and helpful thank
you so much
thank you absolutely
uh all the folks from uh education do a
great job
in uh keeping us informed and
because it is it's a lot of money that
that we have
and and i really appreciate it
so um i have
12 so uh
let us come back if we could at one
and i have a meeting at 2 30
so we will um go from
1 to 2 30 but if we don't finish don't
worry about it
we have other time to uh to take care of
this because we're not
uh you know we're not going to slight
our time
with with education under any
circumstances so
um i guess then that we will recess
until one o'clock and
um i'll see you all then